the worst possible things in the morning
to set their day up for failure what
would they be wake up and stay in bed uh
well wait there are good reasons to stay
in bed in the morning but once those are
completed then staying in bed got
curtains drawn just using your passively
scrolling on social media
neurobiological data showing that when
you are upright you actually are
stimulating this area of the brain
called Locus ceruleus whereas when you
recline you actually are less alert this
is so common now the c-shaped human
thing that it almost feels strange to be
upright say in bed so people are on
their phone they're in bed they're not
getting enough light or they just
artificial light or they're trying to
get the sunlight through the window
terrible they're drinking coffee too
early in the day they aren't getting
into any kind of movement but it's
mostly about the sort of randomization
of activities sort of making a cup of
coffee while texting you know then
they're scattering that in with like a
little bit of work but then they're
building in this eight attention deficit
like disorder